[音楽]
[笑い]
未来の一戦100箱ゲットしまし
[音楽]
たやましいだろうこれ
ね僕のじゃないんですこんにちははじめ
社長ですというわけでポケモンカード
100箱
開封はい今回はこちらの今発売された診断
未来の一戦というポカのボックスを100
ボックス開封していきたいと思いますもう
毎度恒例の企画になりつつありますね
なかなか買えないのでもうだったらみんな
で1ボックスずつ持って集まってあければ
100ボックス回復した気持ちになれるん
じゃないかということでポケモンの
プレイヤー僕僕も含めて100人に集まっ
ていただいてみんなで楽しく開封していき
たいと思います未来っていいよねちょっと
クールな感じがします前回古代を100
ボックスで開けたんですけども今回は未来
を100ボックス開けてまボックスに1枚
運が良ければ2枚SR枠というすごい
キラキラしてるカードが入ってるんです
けどもどんなカードが出るのか何枚出るの
かみんなでこの感動とか悔しさとか
湧き起こると思います100人でシェアし
ながら100ボックス開けていきたいと
思い
ます
[音楽]
それで
はポケモンカード未来の一戦
白すいませ
ん未来の一戦100箱開封を始め
ますよろしくお願いしますペラペラを開け
て
くださいいい音だ今回のレアカードは
リップのスペシャルアートレアそして鉄の
無人のスペシャルアートレアと思われます
当てれように頑張ってくださいでは行き
ます1泊目
スダメでし
たSR出た人ウインガシンウガウン
ガシャン結構出てますね行きましょう
ウインガシャガシャンお願いしますウン
ガシャンウインガシャン
基本鋼エネルギー
URおめでとうございますありがとう
ございますすごいいきなりUR出ました
ウガ
ウガ鉄のカな
[拍手]
SR言わなくて大丈夫
ですウカさんお願いし
[音楽]
ますチルタリス
SARお願いし
ますああ可愛いカネズミ
SR
ウガさんウガ
さんストリンダーEX
SR2バ目
[音楽]
スすいませんでした
ウガウガウガ
さんすごいペースいいですねウガさんウガ
さんお願いし
ますフゥ博士のシナリオ
SARかっこ
いいさん
[音楽]
さんわあかっこいい人EX
SRウンガシャンウガ
シャンリンダEX
SRウガシャンウガ
シン鉄のカナEX
SRウガちゃん
ウガマカネズミ
SRござウガ
ウシリップ
SR可愛い大人の女性好きです
か
[音楽]
キットかっこ
いい
ある個人的に1番今回のパックでかっこ
いいと思ってますどんどん行きましょう3
パック目おす出てくれ出て
くれああダメでした
さんさん
ウウンさんペース早くない
今回
ガガ鉄の買ないX
SRウガシャンウン
ガシン可愛いカネ
SRウガウガお願いし
[音楽]
ます結構出る感じですか鉄の
SRウガウガお願いし
ます
ロボットじゃなくなっちゃってすいません
きました無人
SAR
おとととと
合わせたい人
[音楽]
が
ナイスシイカ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ハンズウインガシャンウィンガシンお願い
し
ます
リップ
SAR
[音楽]
おとはい
ダ
[拍手]
ウガさんウガさんお願いし
[音楽]
ますリダEX
[拍手]
[音楽]
SR
SRもうSトップ出てしまいました4パク
目ウン
がんお願いし
[音楽]
ますギルガルドEX
[拍手]
SRちゃんお願いし
ます
別の会のEX
SRちょっと多いですね鉄の買EXショ
さん多い
です気をつけ
ましょう
かこい博のシナリオ
SR行きますお願いします
プ
SRおとございますありがとうございます
が欲しかったんですかはい出したら交換し
てくださいぜひお願いし
ます
SR
[音楽]
ウウ
リップ
SARおめでとうおめでとうおめでとう
[音楽]
おめでとうございますウシウシお願いし
ますTシャツ来てます
ねトレスEX
SR
ウガウガ
シンわかっこいい鉄の陣
SR私行き
ます行きますウン
ガシャン
ごめん5幕目スフィンガさんフィンガ
ちゃん見てくださいこのカードいいと思い
ませんか史上最強に
可愛いすごいリップ
[音楽]
SARおめでとうおめでとう
パパパパカ
[音楽]
イカシトリンダーEX
SR6バ目おつ2枚箱希望2枚箱ご
希望ウガさんウン
ガシ
ガああレジギガウンガシン
ガシここ出てるなリンダEX
SRカ
さん
お鉄のGXSAR
おめでとうおめでとうおめでとうお
めでとう
[音楽]
ウガさんウガ
さんストリンダーX
SRウガ
さんジップ
SR7パック目
2枚箱2枚箱ああ鉄のカナ
とストリンダーちょっと目立ってますね
ウガちゃんウガ
ちゃん鉄の
SR8バック目
オちゃん
ちゃん
SRウガさんウガ
シンルダスEX
SAR9パック目お早くSR出
たらちょっと寂しいウガ
ウガダ
[拍手]
SRありがとう10パック目
おウンガシャンウィン
[音楽]
ガシャン鉄のEX
SRウンガシャンウガ
シャンリカネズミEX
SRガシャン
ガシャンかっこいいカウンター
キャッチャー
UR
おめでとうございます嬉しいこれ
めちゃくちゃ強いカード金気かかっこいい
ですはい大切にするウィンガシャンウィン
ガシャン普通博士のシナリオ
SRウガさんみ
さん鉄の買の
[音楽]
SR11パック目スウガさ
ウガジップ
SR12パック目
ス違ったウさん
さんEX
SR
さんさん
人
exar
おとおめでとうおめで合わせたい人がいる
んです合ってくれますか結構
[音楽]
です
SRお願いし
ます
い
な
SR
続
[音楽]
SR
SR13パック
ワ願いし
ます
[音楽]
基本鋼エネルギー
UR14パ目ス
[音楽]
リップ
SARおめでとうおめでとうおめでとうお
めでとう
ありがとう合わせたい人があ大丈夫ですお
めでとうございますさんお願いしますお
願いし
ます博のシナリオ
SARガガお願いし
ます博士のシナリオ
SRガシン
ガシンネズミ
exr
鉄の
SR15バック
目絶対に箱
出す絶対2枚はしたい
ガワンピースカードじゃないですねあ
大丈夫ですか大丈夫ですお願いしますお
願いし
ます
[音楽]
今体
ある拍手がちょっとだけ小さいですねガ
ちゃんガちゃんし
ますCX
SR皆さんみ
さん
人
SARおめでとうおめでとうおめでとうお
めでとう
ありがとうあなたに合わせたい人がいる
いや大丈夫です大丈夫です
か基本鋼エネルギー
UR皆さん半分終了
です僕がしていて申ないんですEXが出
すぎてます今9枚出てます残り半分気合
入れていきましょうちなみにまだSR出て
ない人
手ちゃんと板についてる結構いますねまだ
楽しみそうですよろしくお願いします16
番目
スささんさん
さんさん普通博士のシナリオ
SR
じんリップ
[音楽]
SRウガ
ウガ博士のシナリオ
SR17パック目
スさん
シダCX
SARござみしん
[音楽]
シカネズミX
SR並べ方がすごい丁寧まるでロボットあ
まるでじゃないロボット18番目
スそろそろ2枚箱が出てきそうな気がし
ます2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱せーの2枚箱枚箱
枚箱2箱2箱枚箱2箱箱箱箱
箱箱箱
り
[音楽]
基本鋼エネルギー
URおめでとうござい
[音楽]
ます
[拍手]
[音楽]
SRノジ
SRンダ
SR新カード来ました鉄の会EX
SAR
めっちゃ可愛い壁付き破ってる19パック
目
ス
ちゃん兵太
チャンス博のシナリオ
SRノ
sr20パク目
ス
2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱せーの2枚
箱ありがとうござい
ます
リプ
SARおおめでとうおめでとうおめでとう
合わせたい人がいるんですどこですかあ
そうです結構
ですななんでだよ怒らないでください怒ら
ないでくださいさっきまで会ってたろそう
ねそう今戻りましょう今戻り
ましょう失礼しますさおめでとうござい
ますおうござい
ます
ょピさピ
さ
おめでとうございます21泊目ス2枚箱2
枚箱2枚2枚箱2枚箱2枚
箱
ウウ久々に見ましたギルガルドEX
SR22パ
目ウンガシャン
ガシャンチル
SRウ
ウガ
めでとうございます嫌だ
カネズミ
SR23番目
ウさウガ
ネズミ
SRウガシャンウガ
シャン鉄の買のSR
ウガ
ガシン博のなりよ
SRえ皆さんお気づきだと思いますが
トップレアがピタッと出なくなりまし
た兵太の波が寄せていますまだSR出て
ない
人まだ割といますね頑張りましょう24
パック目
ス
2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱せーの2枚箱2箱
枚箱
2ロボットですよねあロボットですあいい
結構ですあえ結構です結構ですかロボット
に会いますよあいいですあ大丈夫ですか
ですか
おいなんでお前俺ってくれないんだ
落ち着いてください落ち着いてくさいたた
よお前落着いてくさいせろ戻りましさん
戻りましょうあっちに戻り
ましょう気持ちは分かりますけどちいて
[音楽]
くださいくない人がいる俺
は
おめでとうございます2枚箱お願いし
[音楽]
ますダEX
SR
さんカウンターキャッチャー
UR
ちゃん
さんさんお願いし
ますリプ
SARおめでとうおめでおめでとうお
めでとうロっときまして
もし
ますありがとうございますおめでとう
ござい
ます25パ目
オス
ったウ
さん
[拍手]
XSR
SR
さんさんお願いしますロボットに会い
たかったのでこれなら会ってくれると思い
ますよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願い
し
ます
体SR26パ目
ス出ない2枚箱がいいウ
さんルEX
SRウグさん
さんようこそ鉄ののEX
SR27パ目お
2枚箱せーの2箱
箱今
ならできますが結構ですかおめでとう
ございますい
ます願いし
ますようこそEX
[拍手]
SR
[音楽]
ダエ
SR
ちゃん鉄の
めでおめで
おでき
ますもういいですやめときますかわかり
まし
[音楽]
ニ
SR28枠
目枚箱2枚箱ダブル2枚箱せー
のパパ僕を抱きしめてパパ僕をガキしね
て鉄の人X
SRおめでとうございます2枚枠お
めでとうございますロボットとあ大丈夫
ですよろしくお願いし
ますスダX
SRウグシウさお願いし
[音楽]
ますノGX
スおとおめでとうおめでとうおめでとう
ございますあちょっとやっぱやめときます
やめときますかすいません分かりまし
[音楽]
たガちゃんガ
ちゃん
TSRさがんバさんお願いし
ます
基本鋼エネルギー
URにけてあげてください2パ
目ようこそ
SR
招待
し
ちゃんちゃん博士のシナリオ
Sござい
ますよこそよう
こそあようこそじゃなかっ
たGX
SRラスト1パクになりましたまだSRが
出てない人立って
ください
[音楽]
1人SR確定ですおめでとうござい
ますでは残りの人でラスト1泊あげ
ましょうまだ2枚箱の可能性あります30
泊目
オス2枚箱来い2枚箱来いあ2枚箱こい
ダメでした2枚箱の人います
かいないかというわけでASR確定
バックス見ていき
[拍手]
[音楽]
ましょうシルタス
SR
[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんお疲れ様でし
[音楽]
た100ボックス開けたSR枠の集計結果
発表したいと思います2枚箱100
ボックス
中6箱でし
た残念ちょっと残念ですやや少ないです
けれども6人の方おめでとうござい
ますでは形106枚の開放結果発表します
SRからリッSR9枚普博士SR7枚兵太
SR6枚鉄の無人EXSR11枚鉄の
カイナEXSR13
枚チルタリスEXSR10枚ストリンダー
EXSR11枚1家ネズミEXSR10枚
ギルガルドEXSR2枚ギルガルドEXが
かなりレアでし続いてURテノ人EXUR
なんと1枚
カウンターキャッチャーUR2枚基本鋼
エネルギーUR5枚結構出てますそして
スペシャルアレアS鉄のカナEXSAR1
枚チルタリスExs3枚鉄の人EX
SAR6枚これはすごい
です普博士SAR3枚RPSAR6枚結構
出て
ます皆さん未来は楽しめましたでしょうか
はい良かったですそれでは次回シャニー
トレジャーでお会いしましょう